Hola, bienvenidos a la presentación
acerca de la fórmula cuadrática,
la fórmula cuadrática tiene un nombre que quizás nos da un poco de miedo por que suena complicado y
abstracto
pero, en realidad
vamos a ver a través de la práctica
que es una cosa relativamente sencilla,
y que es bastante, bastante útil para resolver ecuaciones de segundo grado
o polinomios del segundo grado.
¿Qué significa eso?
Pues empecemos considerando,
algo de la forma 0 es igual a
"x" al cuadrado
-"x" menos 6
y me pregunto
¿Cuáles son los valores de "x"
para los cuales esto es cierto?
Entonces ustedes quizás ya sepan de algún video
o de su clase de álgebra
que lo que se puede hacer es
factorizar el lado derecho de la ecuación.
Lo voy a reescribir
como "x" menos 3
por "x" más 2,
el producto de estos 2
polinomios,
me da este polinomio de acá arriba,
así que bien
si lo que quiero es que esto me de 0,
me tiene que dar 0
entonces, alguno de estos 2 factores
o los 2 se tienen que anular
pero el primer factor
se anula precisamente cuando "x" vale 3,
esto se hace 0,
sí y solo sí "x" vale 3,
y el segundo factor se anula
solo cuando "x" vale -2.
Ahora bien, gráficamente,
¿qué es lo que está sucediendo?
pues para ello,
vamos a pensar en una función,
vamos a pensar en "f" de "x"
que va a estar definida
como "x" al cuadrado menos "x" menos 6,
esencialmente mi ecuación original,
solo que ahora no voy a forzar que sea igual a 0,
va a tomar cualquier valor,
yo simplemente sustituyó aquí,
un valor de "x" y me da un valor esta función.
¿Y qué pasa con la gráfica de esta función?
Pues digamos
que ahí tengo mi eje "x"
y que por acá tengo mi eje "y"
o mi eje "f" de "x",
entonces la función vale 0,
precisamente en 3 o en -2,
lo que eso me dice es que mi gráfica
va a cortar el eje "x"
precisamente en 3...
y en 3
y en -2...
-2 que está por aquí,
-2,
ahora si yo aquí sustituyó "x" por 0
lo que obtengo es 0 al cuadrado,
menos 0 menos 6 que es -6,
por lo tanto cuando "x" vale 0,
que sería sobre este eje,
la función vale - 6...
-6
de modo que la gráfica,
la gráfica debe verse
algo así, más o menos,
no soy muy bueno dibujando,
pero
se dan la idea,
el punto es que encontrar
estos números donde la función se hace 0,
equivale a encontrar las intersecciones
con el eje "x",
a estos números a los que hacen que
la función valga 0,
probablemente
para otro polinomio ya más,
o menos
a esos números se les conoce como las raíces
o los 0 del polinomio "f"  de "x".
Vamos a hacer otro ejemplo,
¿Qué pasa si yo quiero que 0
sea igual a
"x" al cuadrado más 4x más 4?
Entonces
si yo factorizo esto de nuevo
como lo hice acá arriba
esto es lo mismo
que "x" más 2
por "x" más 2.
Quizás reconocieron que este polinomio
simplemente es "x" más 2 al cuadrado,
entonces si 0
es igual a esto,
eso significa que "x"
tiene que ser igual a -2,
en cualquiera de los 2 casos,
por lo tanto,
ésta es la única solución
a este problema,
y lo que nos dice, es que la gráfica de este polinomio,
cortará al eje "x",
precisamente cuando "x" vale -2,
ahora, ¿qué pasa si su polinomio
no es tan sencillo de factorizar?
Consideremos otro polinomio,
vamos a considerar ahora
el polinomio
-10x al cuadrado -9x más 1,
y voy a decir que quiero que 0,
sea igual a esto,
entonces quiero resolver esta ecuación.
¿Para que valores de "x" esto va a ser cierto?
e incluso si dividiera todo entre -10
y lo pusiera en una forma,
en la que sólo está "x" al cuadrado
menos algo más algo,
entonces aún así
no parece que este polinomio
se pueda factorizar fácilmente,
y es aquí precisamente
donde nos ayuda a la fórmula cuadrática,
es lo que voy a introducir ahora
y ésta es una de las pocas cosas
que sí les voy a recomendar
que se memoricen,
y lo que me dice la fórmula cuadrática,
es que si yo tengo una ecuación de la forma
"a"
por "x" al cuadrado
más "b"
por "x"
más "c"
vamos a agarrar el rojo...
y todo eso lo tengo igual a 0,
y noten esta es la forma más general
que puede tomar un polinomio de grado 2,
si apareciera algo
que tiene que ver con "x" al cubo
no sería un polinomio cuadrático
y entonces no podría aplicar la fórmula cuadrática.
Pero bueno lo que me dice la fórmula cuadrática,
es que cuando estás tratando de resolver esto,
entonces
habrán en principio 2 soluciones
y ésas van a ser "x",
que es igual a
-"b"
más menos,
esto puede ser un más
o puede ser un menos,
las 2 son válidas
y cada una de ellas me da una solución,
por eso decía que en general
habrá 2 soluciones,
no siempre pero en general,
pero bien,
más menos la raíz cuadrada
de "b" cuadrada
menos 4 veces "a" por "c"
menos 4 veces
"a"
por "c",
todo eso está
dentro de la raíz cuadrada,
y luego todo esto lo voy a dividir
entre 2 veces "a"....
2 veces "a"...
Así que esas son las soluciones
a un polinomio de grado 2,
entonces en este caso,
si lo que quiero es resolver esto
en este caso,
"a"
es igual a -10,
"b"
es igual a -9,
"a" siempre es el término
que acompaña a "x" al cuadrado,
"b" es el coeficiente de "x"
y "c" es el término independiente
que en este caso es 1,
entonces, bueno,
si sustituyó todo esto,
en la fórmula cuadrática
obtengo que
"x" va a ser igual a -"b",
que sería menos -9, menos más 9,
más menos la raíz cuadrada de
"b" al cuadrado que sería 81,
menos 4 veces...
4 veces "a" que es -10,
por "c" que es 1,
y todo eso dividido
entre 2 veces "a"
entre 2 por -10
Ahora bien, ¿cuánto es esto?
menos -9 serían 9
más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 81
4 por -10 sería -40
pero tengo este menos
así que 81 más 40,
todo eso dividido entre -20.
¿Y cuánto es esto?
Pues esto es
9 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 121.
Todo eso dividido entre -20,
esto es lo mismo
que 9 más menos 11
dividido entre -20,
así que,
como les decía tengo 2 soluciones, tengo...
una solución x1
que va a ser 9 más 11,
primero me voy a tomar el más, entonces 9 más 11,
entre -20,
lo que es lo mismo
9 y 11 es 20
entre -20
que es -1,
y x2,
va a ser igual a
9 ahora me tomo el menos,
9 menos 11
entre -20
9 menos 11 es -2
esto es 1 entre 10,
así que estas son las 2 raíces,
que tiene
este polinomio de acá arriba.
Sus 2 raíces son -1
y 1 entre 10.
La intersección de la gráfica
de este polinomio con el eje "x"
se da cuando "x" es igual a -1
y cuando "x" es igual a 1 entre 10.
En el próximo video
haré muchos más ejemplos
para tratar de aclarar cómo funciona
este bicho,
que es la fórmula cuadrática.